thank you very much and thank you all
for coming let me also use this
opportunity to thank the organizers for
inviting me to go to this workshop and
the entire full I really psyched about
this so i will give you a very very
basic introduction to exponential time
algorithm so i will show a lot of them
and since i got confused about this i
try to summarize what i'm doing while i
do it on this on this blackboard so so
this is the this is the plan so there
are many ways to slice this cake and I
what I like to do is to just use the
standard standard way of us grouping
algorithms into a boxes and see what
comes out of it when you apply that
framework to exponential time
computation so we will see almost all
our friends here except for the greedy
so I have a slightly longer talk where I
try to squeeze in greedy as well but
it's very artificial so so so this is
the plan and i will show you a bunch of
algorithms that fits in each of these
boxes with variants running time I think
nothing i will show you is optimal may
be down here a few things will go okay
so the plan is very much to say that
exponential time algorithms does not in
any significant way defer technically
from what we all know and love from
polynomial time computation except of
course that implanon time computation we
will never use exhaustive search but
here we do and there is a bit to say
about this let me say this first so just
to make sure that we all on the same
page and since I have colored markers so
I think I can stick to these three
problems Hamiltonian cycle which is the
question of visiting all the vertices in
a graph exactly once and I'm so here's
one way of visiting all of them exactly
once graph coloring is a so how fast can
we do this well naively just from the
definition then that would be
this there are potentially n factorial
where n is the size of the graph or the
number of vertices in the graph n
factorial different ways of visiting
these at least one of them will find us
the Hamiltonian cycle so so that would
be our first algorithm for hamiltonicity
similarly graph coloring we can color
this graph with let me try to do it with
two that's not going to work so I need
at least a third color so I can color
this graph with three colors blue white
and yellow no red and obviously I can do
that in time k to the n where k denotes
the number of color so I just check all
mappings from the vertices to the set 1
2 3 up to k and there are K to the end
such mappings one of them will be about
it covering if that exists
satisfiability so here's a small
instance the answer to which is let me
run ppsc on this no so and obviously I
can solve satisfiability by by looking
at all possible evaluation of the
variables and independent set which is
just a very end of this is to find a
large independent set in this graph and
there's one way to screw it up and then
let me try to not do that so there's an
independent set here of size 2 namely
the black one and I can also do that in
time 2 to the N
so that the perfect talk would collapse
the second and fourth column but I
couldn't find an easy way of doing that
now and you might say that everything
about said is now said because obviously
exhausted search is just a question of
iterating over all the possible
witnesses there are so some of these
problems are in RN NP so there's a
natural formulation of this problem ads
give me a witness and then there's a
polynomial time computation left I can
just iterate over all those witnesses
and that gives me the exhaustive search
album but there are a few things to be
said about pad so we want to find a
better than exhaustive search algorithm
for we want to fight better algorithms
than exhaustively searching for a
witness but already this is not very
well defined so it's not quite clear
what what is we're looking for and
here's an example so three colouring the
thing we already have I have in the
blackboard so for k equal three so
obviously i can solve that by looking
for all witnesses the witnesses are
vectors of this length with these values
so i can do that in time 3 to the N and
once I have the witness then it's a
polynomial time computation to see that
for every edge so well given the witness
i can now in polynomial time check for
every edge that its endpoints are
multicolored but if that's okay then why
is not the following as care as well the
wit it would suffice for me as a witness
to see an asset I and independent set so
like this with the following properties
it's independent so it's coloring number
is 1 this is the brief astray I can
write that I is an independent set so it
has chromatic number one and then if the
entire thing was colorable then the then
the compliment we'll have to have a
chromatic number two and the three
candidates sets at least one of them is
less than one third of the size of the
graph so here's my suggestion for a much
better witness the witness is just DM
incidence vector of this subset and
there are this many of them so that's
roughly this time so sim I'm being
almost criminally sloppy with polynomial
factors and so all my running times are
among friends so put all these stars on
euros that you so
well then okay maybe I need a lemma for
this instead don't worry so so the point
here is that this is a polynomial time
computation and so is this so it's easy
to check if a graph is is to cholera
below our first search so for k equal
three we also have this algorithm which
runs in time 1.4 to the M which arguably
is still just search for a witness yes
Angeles we use probably lots of them
yeah i probably need the whatever the
lemma is called the number of maximum
independent sets in a graph is this is
very proper yes thank you 1.89 thank you
very big oh ok ok and another example
instead of doing so here is a witness so
let me let me still a.m. expand the
concept of checking a witness so here's
hamiltonicity in degree three graphs if
the rise Hamiltonian path from s to T
then it goes through some vertex V in
the middle so the graph looks somewhat
like this there's Amal tonian path and s
running through half of the graph going
through V and then running through the
rest of the graph so so this predicate
your hamiltonicity so there in G there
is of Hamiltonian path from s to T if
and only if there is a way to split G
into two sub graphs U and W such there's
there's a path from s to V and then from
V to T and U and V are half the same
size or rather these two sub puffs both
have length and half now this thing I
can if the graph has degree 3 then in
every when I start here or this was a
really confusing illustration of that so
if the graph is degree three not four
then at every vertex once I start
walking around there are only two
choices so in 2 to the N squared time
why is it not to to the end or two
faster than you think you can check this
predicate and you can also check this
predicate that you can put those all
into a large table so if we now so so
here I did it right why can't I see it
now okay you may be is for okay so so
all of these predicates I brutally if
you want to compute and store them in a
huge table so normally I don't have time
for that in our standard understanding
of other witnesses but now I do have
time and space for that because I'm I
care about exponential time computation
so I do that once and after that i
iterate over the remaining half of the
witnesses and check for each of them
that they can be found here so some
people call this meet in the middle or a
time-space trade-off in any case it's
it's it's surprisingly fast are you
talking about for any splitting or a
particular such a splitting must exist
don't you also have to search for the
splitting yeah this is a huge [ __ ] we
will revisit this in a mode this is I'm
not recurring in a recursing on it you
will revisit this in a second so so so
depending on what your what your opinion
of exhaustive search is there is that
there are many non trivial algorithm
sitting up here already let me quickly
move on to local search the other
paradigm that we know we have this so
there is a there is only one important
algorithm here and it's 43 CNF so so
local search algorithms maintain a
current assignment let me call that a
and I'm confusing 0 and false and true
and one so there is a current assignment
here of n bits initially say random and
then I will locally improve this current
assignment as follows so if I'm in an
optimum so if I found an assignment that
satisfies the input formula then I'm
done otherwise in Phi there must be an
unsatisfied clause so under a must
contain somewhere a clause l1 or l2 or
l3 that is unsatisfied so this thing
under a is false so at least one of
these three literals is wrong and I now
flip a 3-sided coin and choose one of
these and and change the value of the
variable indicated by the literal and I
keep doing that
so this is this can be modeled as a
Markov chain so fix a single satisfying
assignment there may be many fix one
let's call that be unknown to us of
course and then consider the following n
plus 1 state Markov chain at the current
time which where the states are the
distances the Hamming distance between
our current solution and the optimal
solution be one of the optimal solutions
be now if the distance is zero our
current solution coincides with the
optimal solution so we are done and it's
easy to recognize that situation so
that's this case otherwise so in this
literal at least one of the valuations
of the variables in this clause defers
in a from what begets etc so at least
one of these when I flip it must move me
closer to a so with probability at least
one-third i will move closer to lay in
that direction and then symmetrically
with probability may be as bad as
two-thirds i will move in the other
direction so the behavior of this
algorithm is pessimistically modeled by
this Markov chain the one that moves
exactly one step to the right with
roughly one-third and one step to the
left with royalty two-thirds and then
you plug that into us so so this is
almost if these said one half then we
would expect what square root of n
square
yeah N squared steps until we hit the
barrier to the right this is worse so
this will be biased towards the left so
once you do the analysis you see that
you after some steps give up because
you're probably too far to the left
start with a new random valuation of a
that will put you somewhere at random
and then again run the mark of step 4 no
markov chain phone number of steps and
unless you hit the barrier you redo this
a bunch of time so this is a nun
exciting analysis of this of this Markov
chain will give you that the expected
running time of this is for over 3 to
the end this is trainings algorithm and
for some reason this seems to be one of
the few local search algorithms we have
in the field of exponential algorithm
which is strange why are there no flow
algorithms that with the interestings
have exponential running times I don't
know
yeah there is more to say but not today
so let's go to the two big big
techniques your recursion and
transformation so of course recursion
again is a known algorithmic technique
maybe maybe the most important one we
have where we reduce a problem to a
version of the same problem typically
for a smaller instance of the problem of
the graph and and this comes in two
flavors decrease and conquer and divide
and conquer so decrease and conquer is
like insertion sort and dividing conquer
it's like merge sort right decreasing
conquer is want to sort all of these and
you do that by finding the largest
element and then recurring on n minus
one of them and dividing concrete is you
want to sort all of these and you do
that by splitting it into two and then
recurring on I think that is a useful
distinction and let's take a look like
this first so algorithms that reduce the
instant size by a constant rather than a
constant factor and and here we now meet
probably one of the richest areas in in
this field these are normally these are
called branching algorithms
so independent set this problem so let's
get the easy case out of the way if the
degree of the graph is 2 or less then
that's an easy case because so then the
graph contains only consist only of
paths and cycles and if it does then
yeah that's easy to solve their own
there's only one choice for each
component and it's easy otherwise there
is a vertex of degree 3 here are managed
to actually draw a graph of degree 3
yeah so otherwise there's a vertex of
degree 3 so consider that vertex and now
there are two cases either V happens to
be in the independent set of the end or
it's not in the dependent set up yet so
let's just build two new instances one
of them both of them consisting of n
minus 1 vertices in one of them we
remember that this was now independent
in the independent set and this is not
an independent set and since we are
changing one instance into two smaller
instances we get this tree and this is
why many people call these things
branching algorithms here we don't have
trees one instance transformed into
exactly one instance so these are paths
here we have trees of instances and so
what I did right now not only doesn't it
quite work it's also not going to be
impressively fast but what you then
observe is that once we decide that this
vertex V should go into the independent
set well then none of its neighbors can
go into the independent set so actually
we have reduced the graph by one vertex
over here and we have reduced it by four
vertices over here one of these four
vertices are in the left sub instance so
the recurrence for
this is a 4 okay so they're running time
for the entire graph is then the
instance to the right which is n minus
at size n minus 1 and the instance to
your left which has size n minus 4 and
if you plug that in then you get 1.39 I
think this value I copied correctly from
a textbook and this not
so he is up 33 if the graph has at least
degree 3 then such a vertex exists if
there is a graph if there's a vertex
with even more neighbors then this
becomes only better if you can I can
throw away even more but if the graph
does not have degree 3 proliferating is
to them I'm in polynomial time these
analyses typically vastly overestimate
the running time of these things because
if you want to implement it and of
course you look for the vertex of
highest degree and branch on that but
this is a guarantee so in practice these
things seem to be very fast but of
course it's unclear what that means so
let's look at another example even older
vertex coloring so here's a graph if the
graph is no edges then the coloring
problem is easy I can just count color
everything pink not consider now the
case where the graph has an edge so the
graph between the edge between U and V
so if there is an edge between U and V
consider two slightly smaller graphs one
graph called G minus UV is the same
graph where I have removed the edge UV
and in the other graph I have contracted
the SUV it doesn't have a name anymore
now
consider a coloring of this scruff so
the colorings of this graph come in two
flavors either the two old UV vertices
have the same color or the same color or
they have different colors so every
coloring of this graph falls either into
this or into that box so red is a
variable that stands for colors hmmm now
these kinds of colorings where u and V
have received different colors are
isomorphic to all valid colorings in
this graph because I can just add the
edge these colorings are isomorphic to
all valid colorings in this graph
speakin a second controller contract the
edge ok so I can count the colorings in
this graph by counting them here and
here and adding these two values or
maybe more interestingly I can count the
colorings in the original graph by
counting these colorings and then
subtracting these colorings
ok so if P for a while for a moment
denotes the number of colorings of the
graph G then p satisfies this recurrence
the number of colleagues and G is the
number of colleagues in G minus UV minus
the number of colleagues and G minus you
can track V and this is a now again a
decrease in concora currents are not
recording on graphs where throw away
where I throw away vertices button
graphs where I throw away edges or
contract them but otherwise the
computation trees again binary every
instance produces two new instances the
recurrence now has looks a bit harder to
analyze because there are two parameters
and number of vertices and the number of
edges so in this case the number of
edges goes down and in this case which
is this one both the number of vertices
and the number of edges goes down so one
parameter to our to analyze this under
is the sum of these two values so the
running time in terms of n plus M
satisfies this mono variate recurrence
so n plus M is either reduced by one or
it's reduced by two and this is of
course the famous recurrence known to
even the readers of bad crime fiction
because it converges to the golden ratio
and this so this is the famous deletion
contraction recurrence by feudal how do
I say that z cough what I said map ok
and I and I have to apologize I'm not
only are my bounce sloppy I simply
didn't find the time to put references
on all my slides so maybe I can upload
them somewhere and put all the names
there somewhere huh
one point
so this is this is it seldom better than
than this but sometimes it is it's
certainly a non trivial algorithm and as
I said optimality is not my my
motivation here I just want to show you
a bunch of different algorithmic
techniques and what they have to do in
this realm
okay yeah doesn't seem to be your couch
doesn't seem to be tight well I can show
you graphs that have this many sub trees
much larger than n cuz then then you
would prefer the other there is an evil
twin to this recurrence called the
addition contraction routine where it's
better to add edges okay and let's see
what this says to say 43 sad yeah but
you will know this but let me just do it
anyway so if all clauses have two
literals then this is just to CNF which
is easy otherwise there must be a clause
that looks like this it has three
literals called XYZ and I will now
produce for new instances so in the
first instance I set X to true and clean
up the rest of the graph so that gives
me one instance with one less variable
and the next instance I said X to false
+ y2 true and clean up the graph so that
gives me one instance of size n minus 2
and then there is one instance of size n
minus three and one more so because I'm
not concentrating I'd I made this
mistake so so that gives you this
recurrence which then unsurprisingly of
course gives you exactly what you
started with because we haven't done
anything intelligent here but the
observation is now of course that these
instances are useless because we already
killed one of the clauses so there's no
way that the solution will satisfy the
entire graph so we don't have to
consider this case there are only these
three interesting cases so this two goes
away and then you get this recurrence
for 1.84 to the end
not not even close to optional but it's
a it's a very easy algorithm to convince
yourself that they're non trivial
algorithm for three set so what does
this have to say for Hamilton icity then
so if there is a path from s to T then
the path has to go from s by an edge to
some neighboring vertex and then
traverse the rest of the graph from v2g
so if i express this as a recurrence
then there's a Hamiltonian path in G
from s to T if and only if there is one
from v2g where v goes over all neighbors
to s so the idea is to start from s then
exhaustively search through all
neighbors and then start a recursion in
the rest of the graph the light blue
graph starting here that's g- probably t
minus s yeah G minus s thank you so I'm
tempted to sort of correct this but
Alistair won't be happy yeah
yeah it's jamin it's unclear whether
yeah it's G minus s I'm trying to okay
and this is of course a terrible idea
because so now I have reduced the
problem of size n to a bunch of and
probably many these could be all
vertices problems of size n minus 1 so
oh that's not even n factorial were so I
descend to the end yeah it's n to the
end ok but then the graphs become
smaller so probably in fact oh sorry
dropping because you go G where the NS
dropping yes fine yes good having good
ship so this is a terrible idea but but
it's not because because as you see
almost all the so how many different
arguments do we call h on h these things
this is always fixed this varies over n
different values of V and this is every
subset of the graph in the worst case so
I'm never going to call this on more
than 2 to the N different instances so
why don't I tabulate all of them and
this is of course the idea that goes
back to bellman so there are only n
times 2 to the n different table entries
so I can pre-compute all of them and put
them in a table and never recompute them
and then the running time can't be worse
than what it took to fill out this this
table and this we know today by the
direction the Belmonts term for this was
dynamic programming and and this
algorithm so this silly recurrence and
this brilliant idea together is is of
course super famous so this is 2 to the
N time it's and it's part of popular
culture right so everybody knows this
because because it appears in a webcomic
a webcomic I point out that is more
diligent in actually putting correct
running times in its drawings than I am
and of course you can you can go further
and further back in time if you if you
really want then then one of the oldest
examples of a decrease and conquer
occurrences the Laplace expansion for
the determinant which as given here
again gives you a terrible running time
but you can just memorize all these
miners and there are only two to the end
of them so the Laplace expansion gives
you also roughly two to the N table
entries times n times n squared times 2
to the N table entries you can do with
so so you can do the determinant and
also the permanent in this running time
and have been able to do so since 1700
actual dynamic programming is from 1959
but yeah there's there's another
algorithm for determinants that would
appear in a hypothetical workshop on
polynomial time computation yeah but the
the beauty of this one is that it works
even if if even if your occurrence isn't
so friendly as to have a term you that
makes everything cancel at the right
time so so the same expression without
that is the recurrence for the permanent
which didn't make the cut apparently
okay
we can extremely let me go back to the
recurrence I had early on for
hamiltonicity so this is still true and
and why don't I now just instead of
using it only at the top why don't I
just recurse on this so i can adjust it
managed to express h in terms of H so I
can run this recursively instead of
running it only instead of what I did in
the beginning to exhaustively compute
this and build a table for this I now
take this as a recurrence and and well
how many how many partitions are there n
over n half partitions into roughly
equal sized sets and then you probably
also have to multiply this by n but the
subproblems have size n half so there's
probably a factor n squared missing but
nothing big enough to change the
correctness of this so this if you so
the recurrence gives you four to the M
times I think n to the log in
reveal so let's write this this does not
look so good in comparison to this but
this is a polynomial space algorithm
this algorithm uses no extra space and
and one of the so this algorithm used
two to the N space and two to the N time
and this algorithm uses polynomial space
and four to the end time and so since
two times two is four this seems to be
important but who knows it's certainly
an interesting problem to see if the
trade-offs that exists between these
things are are necessary what is this if
not again
that's the factor that's x to you then
over to i guess i want to also look at
this what happens when i memorize this
recurrence so
so as you might want to fill a table
with this how many table entries are
there are two to the end table entries
for every table entry say the table
entry of size are I have to look at all
ways to split the subset of size r into
two equal sized subsets and there are
roughly two to the r of those so this
will become the N so you're missing it
and choose K there that in that second
term once you stick it in yes exactly
i'm missing the n choose k exactly take
this entry skate here as well and then
you get that that if you throw dynamic
programming after three currents then
you end at three to the end so that's
now worse than here and uses the same
space so here turned out to not be a
good idea but you never know so now the
product between time and space is six to
the end which is worse than both this
and that
see here I explain to myself what I yeah
yeah okay colouring so so this is the
obvious recurrence for for coloring and
when you do with the computation it's
it's not going to be very good so I
split the I split the input into two
sets I've aerial controller with a large
one so so we get exactly here did it
right here the binomial coefficient
actually made the made it to the slide
we get a 3 to the n algorithm for
coloring and this is Lola's algorithm so
so I split the thing into two sets
compute recursively the chromatic number
of the left one provided that's an
independent set so that chromatic number
is always going to be one and then I
crew i compute the chromatic number of
the rest so that's me minus I so I look
I minimize over all subsets I for which
the left side is easy simply by running
through all independent sets and then
the right side and so it's a very
lopsided divide n conquer thing so and
and in order to do that then at size ki
have to split into two equal sides set
which is roughly two to the K size so
that gives us this running time for
graph coloring with exponential space
this is lower 1973
just for completeness there is an other
way to split the chromatic number into a
sum of other chromatic numbers because
so I will now try partition the graph
into three sets I U and V such that I is
independent so it has chromatic number 1
and u and V each are less than half the
size of the graph so you can always do
that so there is a way so U and V
themselves are the unions of disjoint
independent sets so there is a way to
distribute these three parts such that
neither of you and v is larger than half
the size of the graph if there were then
i'd take out one of the independent sets
and make that I and that gives you this
recurrence so now X this is now a
property writing conquer occurrence into
two different subsets where I recursion
both of them and so the Wreckers the
recurrence is then going to be the
number of try partitions so the number
of ways to do this times two times the
the recursive calls here and if you
compute that the outcome will be 9 to
the end so terrible but in polynomial
time follow me space with melanoma
spaces thank you go here apathy coloring
or a four so why you looking for
bipartisan above issue allah says in
organizations not three currents this is
this is this is k coloring okay it's
just you know i find the chromatic
number i compute the chromatic number i
can compute the chromatic number of the
graph by using these to divide and
conquer algorithms this one actually
happens to be good for 20 years this was
the best algorithm for chromatic number
for a long time this was the best
algorithm for chromatic number and and
it's non-trivial because Q does not
appear here the number of colorings does
not appear in the expression which is
surprising because you would expect the
number of colleagues to appear and
indeed there are some very easy
constraint satisfaction problems that
almost look like coloring problems where
the number of states or colors does
appear okay this was recursion so where
we take the problem and produce one or
two or many smaller versions of the same
problem in some transformed graph remove
an edge remove a vertex contract an edge
or split the graph into a constant
fraction size sub graphs
breathe and now the next and final
family of problems is going to be
transformation where we take the problem
and translate it into something else and
then solve that problem and then
translate the argument it translate the
result deck so this is reduction if you
want and most of the recent exciting
progress in this field has been here and
and there's simply too much for what for
a talk but let me just give you a whiff
of what happens here so so here's one
prop so all of these but all of the
other than half have the form that we
take the problem and reduce it to
something else that we know something
absurd izing about so the problems on
the right side those who transformed to
allow some surprising algorithm and and
and here's one the sum of two sets of
vectors so this this goes by many many
names split and list me to the middle
sort and search so here it is at least
in a toy version we have two sets of
vectors a and B and the target vector T
in D dimensions I want to find a sum
where a one term is from one set and the
other term is from another set such that
the sum hits the target director exactly
so here's an example here's my set a and
here's my set B and here's my target t
so and now you all run the quadratic the
obvious quadratic time algorithm is to
take this and compare it with that and
that's going to give us 0 0 3 2 1 and
that's not going to work and you
iterator all of them and then after
quadratic time you find that these match
okay and and the surprising thing is
that you can do something better by one
of the most important algorithms we have
namely sorting well you laugh but I mean
this is some sorting is's is highly
non-trivial thing so so the idea is to
first sort be because every time I have
a concrete vector on my left side and
there in my hand I know exactly which
lecture on the right side I'm looking
for so if I had easy access to all of
them say by sorting or hashing or
whatever your favorite data structure is
if I could quickly look up does this
vector in this case 0 0 1 0 1 existing
be yes or no then I could then I could
find it and that gives me a faster
algorithm so so how do we use that for
an exponential time problem here's a toy
example exact conjunctive normal form
satisfiability not even close to the
fastest algorithm for this problem but
let me show it to you so exact SAP means
that every in a satisfying assignment
every clause has one and only one true
literal so here is my example instance
with five clauses and the transformation
is now the following I split the set of
variables in 22 WX the first two and
then everybody else which will be said
and why later and now construct all
possible assignments to W and X and I
failed because this should see TT
but better people than I could actually
this is correct so this should say false
false false true true false true true
and for each of these assignments i
compute for every clause the number of
true literals in that clause so for
instance let's take let's take this guy
so one two three four 1234 fly claim
that for the assignment w falls ex Falls
this clause has exactly two two literals
and this is going to be true and this is
going to be true and this I don't know
so this has two literals or rather this
assignment leads to too satisfied
literals in closed form and I do that
for all the clauses and for all the
variables so that gives me 2 to the n
half rows and n columns ok and now I but
most of you should now be able to see
the reduction so so I do the same thing
for the other two variables why is it
the other in half variables and here I
succeeded and then you can see that i
was actually yeah now you can all see
that this thing mess with this this is
actually exactly the same instance that
I showed you on the previous slide so so
the target vector is now going to be a
bunch of ones one one one on one so time
and space is 2 to the N off rather than
2 to the N 2 to the N half times n plus
the time for sorting and so um so what
this is here exact sat due to the enough
using exponential space
so what we've done here is to take a
relatively small instance to our heart
problem and transformed it into a huge
instance for our easy problem solve that
using an surprising album for the easy
problem and then it into interpreted the
solution back let me do that again now
mapping to something else for which we
know surprising algorithm namely finding
triangles which exploit the fact that
there's an surprising algorithm for
triangle multiplication right matrix
multiplication so we want to find we
want to count the number of triangles in
this graph and there is one and then
dear nice algebraic way of doing that is
to consider the the adjacency matrix
take that to the third power and then so
what's the combinatorial interpretation
of this thing there's a two here or
there's a two here because you can go
from this vertex there are two lengths
three paths that go from this vertex and
back here's one and here's the other
did I set path walks right so Mon
softest of length 3 from V back to be so
in total there are so there are two walk
walks from be back to V two here and two
here and on here so so every triangle is
going to be counted six times you're my
one triangle is going to be counted six
times one for each of these vertices in
both directions so algebraically 16 of
the trace of a cubed is going to be the
number of triangles in the graph so
instead of triangle counting or
detecting you can take the incidence
matrix take it to the third power and
since there is a surprising algorithm
for matrix multiplication you can do
this faster than the naive algorithm
right so to sum this up there are two
ways of finding triangles one is to look
at all sub or two it to iterate over all
pairs of three vertices and see do they
form a triangle or you could do this and
plug this into your favorite matrix
multiplication algorithm which will be
which will have a running time of charm
of the dimension of the matrix in this
case n to the Omega where Omega is a
number surprisingly much smaller than
three
so how do we use that for our problem
let me find a cake lick and I could only
draw a six click instance for you so the
example is K click here's a concrete
instance for k equal six I will build
myself from this smallish instance I
will build a huge instance to the
triangle detection problem and then
solve that using the matrix
multiplication algorithm so there will
be one vertex here for every k / 3 click
here so the k / 3 clicks are just the
edges which means i can actually draw
this so so so this to click is this
vertex and this to click is this vertex
and so on so there's one vertex for
every k / 3 click in the original
instance and then there is an edge
between two two clicks if and only if
they are as connected as they can be so
let me show an example this to click the
red one and this to click the green one
all their end points are connected this
is quickly checked and so I put an edge
there whereas the green click and the
black click even though they do share an
edge they are not as connected as they
could be so they don't get an edge in
the transformed to instance
and now this enormous instance will have
a triangle exactly if this thing has a
six click and you can see that these
three guys will form a triangle and
indeed they do even they do form six
click in the original instance so the
running time now then is the dimension
of the matrix or the number of vertices
in the resulting graph to the Omega so
that's going to be n to the Omega K over
three and so that the thing to note is
that Omega is less than three so this is
two point 3/3 rather than three be
divided by three which would be the
obvious thing so their independence
hadn't click are the same among friends
sir is there a variance to this 4k isms
in our three year our 33 times two I
guess then you can just put a number of
dummy purchases in there and then the
reduction should still go mm-hmm but but
this is surprising but it shouldn't mean
yeah it's surprising because matrix
multiplication is surprising and then
yeah just to show you one of the more
recent algorithm so that I particularly
like another surprising thing you can do
in polynomial time is to given a
polynomial like this one quickly check
if the polynomial is the zero polynomial
so you can all try to do that in your
head is this the zero polynomial if I
give it like this and and as you will
all observe the only thing you can do is
to factor these things out and that so
that's roughly going to be exponential
in the length of the polynomial the
answer is yes so this is the question we
want to so answer and there is a
surprising algorithm for that which is
far better than triangle points there or
factoring the polynomial and that is
exploiting the fact that we all know
from from calculus that polynomials
don't have too many zeros so unless F is
the zero polynomial then in a random
point it's not going to be zero so this
is the Schwartz sippel lipton more and
more authors added to this lemma the
mill yeah
so again a surprising a well known
algorithm and and this takes an hour or
two to do in all theatres I just want to
get to give you the gist of this here's
an instanced hamiltonicity I will
construct a polynomial by decorating the
edges of the original instance with
formal variables and then consider this
polynomial so I can always define this
and so it's a it's a sum over all
permutations of the product of the
variables appearing on on that
permutation so the permutations include
usefully the Hamiltonian cycle see is
one permutation through the graph so
here can draw it here so that's going to
give us a polynomial with a bunch of
terms one of which is exactly this
permutation which goes x1 x2 x3 x4 x5 67
so here it is so this is not going to be
the zero polynomial because this had a
Hamiltonian path unless since the
computations in a finite field it's
cancelled by something else and that's
exactly what we need to avoid for
instance these permutation so this is
also a permutation of the year of the
vertices but it's not a Hamiltonian
cycle so in this world it will give us
it will give us the terms x 2 x 7 x 10
to 7 10 followed by 4 8 11 4 8 11 but
there's another permutation that will
give us exactly the same terms and here
it is so this permutation and then this
cycle followed in the other direction so
11 8 for 11 8 4 so if we do this in in
an algebra the proper properties than
this thing and this thing are the same
as long as soon as these are associative
so in characteristic to these will
cancel so this is one of the three major
tricks to you need to make this work I
have this example only to show you that
there is a way to transform a
combinatorial question about the
existence of psychosis in graphs into a
question that boils down to evaluating a
polynomial in a sufficiently precisely
defined finite field has to have
characteristic to has to be associative
and and yeah this still doesn't work and
it's not even fast but many many details
are or without but in the end you want
to know is this the zero polynomial and
it's going to be the zero polynomial
exactly if this is not hamiltonian with
high with some probability so that gives
you a randomized algorithm for
hamiltonicity and haim 1.66 to the m
1.67 maybe i'm not sure actually and
yeah they're lots of beautiful papers
written in this so the thing the three
things i showed you all transform our
problem p into some other problem that
we already know is easy so we had these
three examples matrix multiplication
this a twosome problem and and
polynomial identity testing so here you
then have to work hard to understand
what exactly is this transformation that
gives us gets us from our known problem
from our given problem to one of the
tiny handful of known problems that are
hard so there is one other technique
which which is a very clean here where
you take p and then you always apply the
same transformation called the zeta
transform of this problem and then you
end up with whatever is here and then
you try to do something about this so so
in in this family of problems that
transformation is given and then you are
faced with the result and have to find a
clever algun for this here your
algorithms are given and you try to find
a transformation that gets you there and
luckily I don't have time for the zeta
transform those my favorite thing so so
this is a there's a very clean way of
explaining this where you take a problem
transform this to to this problem
basically by summing the original
problem H
over all subsets and that gives you
another problem and then sometimes you
unlock and this problem actually you can
be solved faster than you thought and
then you transform it back so both the
transformation back and forth are
typically exponential time and the
solutions here are also often but not
always exponential time there's one
famous counter example due to riser who
was the first to discover this that you
can transform the question of counting
the number of perfect matchings in a
graph into this and going from here to
there is exactly the zeta transform and
these problems turn out to be polynomial
time computable but the cedar transform
itself takes exponential time so the
entire thing takes exponential time and
there's another example for coloring but
I'm luckily out of time so that's it so
maybe one final remark about this in
particular the later problems here
certainly these three techniques sorry
these three techniques have this
opportunity will exponential time
algorithm we exploit non-trivial
polynomial time algorithms so the
examples I showed you here exploit these
in a positive good and happy fashion in
that I'm trying to actually solve a
problem faster by exploiting some other
polynomial time problems faster
algorithm but what is becoming clear
during the later years in which i think
belief will be a theme of course will be
that that this works in the other
direction as well but maybe at least in
this perspective it shouldn't have been
a surprise that hardness results for
exponential time problems imply Arden's
results for polynomial time problems
exactly because algorithms for
polynomial time problems in flight and
have for a long time implied sub
exponential time non trivial algorithms
for for exponential time problems and
with this optimistic
somewhat programmatic comment I end my
talk perfectly on time and thank you for
your attention
any questions ruining the perfect
profession of the timing know what
there's